hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
coverage of e3 2019 I am Michael Hardy
here with Lucy James know and we've got
a really exciting interview about to
happen right now we have Thomas and both
from remedy you guys have been working
on control nuts looking forward to
seeing how it unfolds in August but
let's get into it what have you been
showing at e3 this year that is new to
people I want to take that one I'll take
that one so when we introduced a game
last year we started off with
introducing the whole game as a concept
and what was important for us that we
show that there is excellent cool
explosive gameplay in this experience
and a lot of mystery as well at a large
world that you can uncover and now that
we're getting closer to the release it
was important we start showing off the
Lacetti more human side of the
experience so you will see in your demo
friendly and PCs that you can talk to
and you get a kind of a closer
connection to what's at stake what are
the other people here what they're going
through and and they will help you and
you can help them and also what we want
to start open up is the background story
of Jesse a bet and basically we learned
that when she comes this place she's
actually trying to find out what has
happened to her brother in her childhood
she was in this kind of a strange
supernatural event and her brother was
there as well and then what happened was
that this organization fara birth
control came there and actually took her
brother and she managed to escape and
after all of these years he has finally
found out where the Bureau is and now
she's come to this place Lukie France
was trying to find out what happened to
her brother it's not like in a gameplay
sense control kind of sells itself as
soon as you start watching it what why
why the decision to make this like human
more emotional story when you could just
like make it a third person game with
like
and I like force powers sorry I couldn't
quite hear the question I'm just curious
like what what goes into the thinking to
make like to add this emotional depth to
it when it you could probably just keep
it this fun crazy story yeah I mean
we're remedy right like we're all about
characters and interesting world you
know compelling experiences gameplay is
always important for us evermore to make
that as responsive and fun as possible
but honestly at the end of the day it's
kind of combining the world the
characters to plot a gameplay and only
that to really make an experience that
is fun to play and fun to experience
overall and to be able to be invested in
the experience we need to have
characters they can relate to a world
that you can't understand so that you
you feel invest that you want to you
want to help you want to be a part of
this and but when we started to put this
kind of a core concept together it was
important we started off with the world
like what is this place that you want to
go to and you want to return to so that
was the starting point but as we kind of
worked further and further than you know
we started to add like these other
characters and other plot lines or so I
mean so what came first was it the you
know this setting three there smacks of
horror movies David Lynch I mean where
did the inspiration for you know the
setting and the tone of the game come
from before you start adding the story
beats so after doing games like quantum
break I wake I'm Max Payne which are
very story girl very linear experience
that are great there's a place for those
type of games but both me and Sam we
wanted to do something different this
time and instead of starting with the
screen players we usually do or like
establishing characters and plot lines
we instead started with the world itself
like what is this world and that's what
we came up with the idea of this
organization that Bureau oldest house
was just a strange place the
supernatural place of power
that seems to be infinite into all
different directions and and that's how
we came up with the hiss which is the
supernatural force that has invaded the
place and then we started to actually
talk about okay who are the different
characters that worksheet existence as
well what do they go through even the
idea that you would play as the director
of this organization actually came
afterwards and the reason why we
approached it like that was that we
wanted it to be a sense of discovery for
the player there's not just one main
campaign that you go through and then
you're done there's a lot of other
things you can do as well there's side
missions this exploration there's a lot
of other place you can go and kind of
find more more about this world like
what are the kind of reasons for certain
things to exist and so it was like a
world first type of thinking instead of
story first or kind of gameplay aside so
and it was a big change for us we had to
think about things a bit differently and
but that kind of a mentality was there
from day one that it's more about the
world and then we'll kind of figure out
the rest kind of a loaded question I
realize but how would you describe like
Remedies games and how is that DNA
making its way into control really good
questions for you but I mean I am sure
the answer is that you know we make
third-person action games and that's at
the part of control as well and we do
have this discussion back at the studio
like what what exactly makes this like a
remedy game because when the trailer
came out at e3 last year it was
interesting to see the reactions on line
of people like fifteen thirty Seconds
into the trailer oh that that's from
remedy and we're like is it the lighting
is it the art is it the the vibe I think
it's it's it's all of those things and
we do like to get a bit weird and we
definitely want to kind of like keep
that remedy tone in there I mean we can
say it's that finished aspect to the
game but then then again remedy what we
might be in Finland but like half the
companies for and so I don't know it's a
very good very very good mix and all of
that kind of comes
get her to make the games I think part
of it is as well that care and
dedication that we put into realizing
this worlds is immense
like me and Sun and the entire remedy is
that it would care a lot about this
experience that we create there's a lot
of thought that they put into the
details of this experience and and that
was what we think about a lot when we
were working on quantum break that they
might have going to put into that world
but then at the end of the day it's a
very linear experience it's just blast
through it and so we wanted with control
find a way of how do we take all of that
kind of energy and passion that they put
into the creation of this world but
build a game structure that allows
people to actually dive into it and
experience that without just focusing on
the main plot at all times what I think
of Max Payne when I think of quantum
break it's funny I think about how those
games feel to play I don't know if you
could describe it but how would you
describe the way you want control to
feel when you're playing it right after
a quantum break we put a lot of energy
and time into making sure that the
character comes across as very cinematic
very physical unbelievable but it also
led to a certain kind of a slowness to
the kind of movement or response times a
zone so we control what was important
for us that it is very responsive and
quick in media so when you play the game
whatever you want to happen happens
right away so you get this really strong
sense of control of the character and so
to to make it actually feasible we had
to update our animation system we we
accepted our physics engine as well and
actually operated the AI system as well
so there's a lot of technical work that
actually has happened in the engine and
an if use part of that was just ensure
that we have this really snappy
responsive gameplay experience and it is
very fast-paced
aggressive game fight of the experience
in the
you can tell kind of hide behind covers
and wait it out you need to dive in five
I mean one of the things we discussed
really early on in production was like
we know how to make gunplay feel good
that that's relatively relatively easy
but then the bigger question was how can
we make using Jessi's abilities feel
feel as good so when you use launch
which is the telekinetic ability to grab
objects and roll them like if it doesn't
feel good players won't use that so it's
about a sense of way to the animation
the the audio everything has to come
together that took a very long time and
we've spent a lot of time working on
kind of beep we didn't want you to have
to really point at objects to be able to
grab them at all you have to just glance
at them a click hold down the button and
chill immediately kind of grab the
object so that that takes a lot of work
to make it feel good but the response
has been really really good introduced
throughout the game is it either there
from the get-go or is it something that
we're gonna be gradually learning over
time and how do you touch it it briefly
there about how to how you created them
but how do you balance using powers with
using guns in the moment-to-moment
gameplay yeah well I mean we won't want
to leave it to the player so if you want
to use the service weapon or you can I
mean you can tweak and upgrade it but
then it's also after repairs if they
just want to really focus on the
abilities and customize them and operate
them so they can sort of you know the
cooldowns will be quicker and all of
those things and balancing a game is
really difficult I mean that's that's
what we're doing right now it will be
very
I mean players tend to we all tend to
default to whatever is going to be
easiest so getting that careful balance
for like using the abilities and the
service weapon are both fun is is tricky
but obviously that's what we're really
trying to try to achieve but as for the
abilities I mean you get launch is the
first thing you get and then as you
progress through the story you get more
abilities but then it's kind of up to
the players to kind of really
explore the oldest house and find mods
for the abilities and the service weapon
and so on Thomas and Mika unfortunately
that is all the time we have control is
not too far off right a couple months
now what's the exact date we can play
this game
August 27th it's coming wait till sword
sopia team back home make it happen
alright guys thank you so much for
joining to talk about control good luck
with everything leading up to the
release if you're watching from home we
will be back after a very short break
with the outer worlds
[Applause]